it has been so long and my path has been
so dark darker than I ever dreamed it
could be but we're finally gonna watch
this Star Wars fan film that's been
requested for so long Darth Maul
apprentice from the channel t7 Pro but
hey before we go into that it's sellout
time except we're not really selling out
because today's sponsor is actually
pretty awesome giant panda King which is
what my mom calls me that doesn't sound
so internationally a gpk is best known
for their touring star wars burlesque
show the Empire strips back but they
also work across print podcasts film and
more I genuinely mean it when I say that
they make extremely high quality parody
content that takes geek in popular
culture to a whole other level
and recently they sent us over their
flagship magazine also set in the Star
Wars universe called wookie rhotic think
like an old 70s playboy that your dad
would hide under his mattress when he
was a kid if he grew up on Tatooine ha
ha ha ha ha he stole my joke I made that
joke off-camera and we actually read the
whole thing from cover to cover that's
what my dad would tell my mom what but
he's right we did read the articles and
everything in here what's wrong with
your parents honestly these things are
wildly immersive featuring authentic
feeling ads articles interviews and
erotic comics steeped in the Star Wars
world of mythology and of course Marburg
girls seriously yeah you're gonna have
to grab the mag for yourself if you want
to see because this is definitely not
YouTube advertiser friendly and on top
of that I read this next thing in the
matter of two days this incredible
Gotham 1919 to 1939 book and they take
the Batman characters and the mythology
and they transport them into America
during the Great Depression it's
wonderful these books are incredibly
lived in and constructed and they're
almost like reading a graphic novel in
their own right so please go ahead hit
our special link you will not regret it
and head on over to gpk to check these
out for yourself and see what else they
got in store seriously it means a lot
I'm trying to get free tickets to that
burlesque show yeah would be fun if we
went I don't want to take you I want to
take my sister are you still going to
therapy
[Music]
[Music]
for a lot of great things about as well
to us the annihilation of our people
will not
years we had way too high
observing but our time to strike is
finally yet
No
blinded by arrogance and limited by
compassion they choose to deny the true
nature of the cause that makes makes us
to house
but until then our presence must be kept
hidden we cannot make them know what we
are planning you must protect our
secrets and of course
[Music]
Oh party in love with this I want a
hollow bubble
any intruder must be destroyed
immediately this is like four years old
it looks still incredible yeah not that
four years ago I was like forever ago
but still it isn't technology whatever
yes sir they take not technology
speaking yeah
I'm getting comforted to the source of
the signal curly hair let Jedi wait I
think there's something else
[Music]
great
Oh
oh you didn't even double believe it no
one
what an entrance then oh sweet
[Music]
we must inform the council there is no
time we have to deal with the door
ourselves
once he'd art involved earlier
Oh
you are - this is great
ah
[Music]
yeah no one makes me bleed my own blood
this is incredible choreography ok shots
dude
Oh God
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
this is better than all the Disney
fights it really is though oh yes Oh
Oh
oh it's like watching video game you
gotta scan I play a ball too could mean
the end for all trust me they're all
dead
my dude
I still haven't slept with your fighting
Stephanie's a month ago
[Music]
it's badass
[Music]
he done pissed off the wrong SIF man
let us leave we already lost too much
together don't be afraid
thank you he's gonna come back with a
ship its rocket love you guys pay my ass
where they shoot this
that's a great wish that's why I go
there
[Music]
so cool wire mechs are great
yes
a man like you but I want mall the way
oh you got this apprentice don't worry
there should be a show there should be a
live-action show I mean it would
cauterize I guess
[Music]
[Music]
use it - yeah
incredible
[Music]
get up young Jedi
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is it a killer to blink I love this man
[Music]
[Music]
like a samurai Western standoff so great
a fistful of imperial credits better
higher Ned please
[Music]
yes
[Music]
Rayshawn is
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
heaven skiddo like every horse on
use the Force Harry
[Music]
come on just become a sit
do it
there's a darkness Center
they're being watched dude
[Music]
ah
[Music]
I am i I love the way they handle Hannah
how got us so great you have done well
my apprentice the force is strong with
you let this [ __ ] here for you oh and
every kid has made you stronger no mercy
no compassion and it's you he's what you
really powerful
your training is complete this is the
beginning of the end
she died
[Music]
whoa ooh oh man whoo God that is that
was incredible
that was very mess that's one of the
absolute best fan films I've ever seen
in my life
sounds like equivalent to when people
have us watch like video games cinematic
trailers that's so good I feel like the
Star Wars should just start acquiring
these and putting them out you should be
like an anthology show yeah like a
live-action anthology show at this point
they should just make some kind of
official thing well you made a fan film
it's good just we'll showcase it you
know the guy played Darth Maul was great
yeah he was really great especially
having to act through just body language
and all that makeup I mean yeah he
communicated a lot with his eyes and his
expression I love that the way that
finally I would have been so upset if he
spared her life no but I love the moment
of conflict that he has there and then
all he's doing right that made this
great job on the direction to have cut
her into the camera knowing he's being
watched knowing he's being test he could
feel all this that I'm saying yeah and
you could all that conflict is resonated
in him in that rage and there's a like
this humane pathos brought to the
character here his soul there's like a
layered for four bits without it's easy
to chalk it up to I just gonna be quiet
but that's not it man like there's a lot
that he there's a lot that he was
communicating just through the body
language and the facial expressions is
real like haunted performance I thought
and then right Darth gosling over here
hello it's yeah yes
DEFCON unlimited
but also I gotta say to a lot of the
time when um about size it avidity like
fan films were independent or films that
I would shoot like in the park or
something good place to get exterior
locations and this is one of the rare
cases it's like they chose location I
was just like you know there's a park
and you know this is like sand beach
front oh that was I was I would love to
see it behind the scenes on this because
yeah everything about this was so well
executed yeah these people better be
making films and stuff in a like they
better get funding for stuff if this
didn't help out everybody involved I'm
going to be sorely upset that's Danny
villainy who directed the tone and the
mood of the entire piece was so felt
there that the menacing presence that
they had a bit of like a somber
melancholy tone mixed in with that dark
that had some of that haunting drive
behind it
menacing undertones I thought the
choreography was so great it was more
than just like cool style throughout
there was like storytelling within the
fight we know that you know Darth Maul
apprentice fan film probably gonna win
it was a constant game of strategy and
then having to figure each other out and
Maul figuring them out that main Jedi
and figuring him out the way the
back-and-forth went on it there was like
a constant build and that's what kept
this suspense alive in it it's something
that I thought that Disney trilogy tried
capturing with their fight scenes
you got the mix of the cool hyper
stylized choreography from the prequels
and then you get the best of both worlds
here I thought getting some cool
choreography but communicating so much
in just its tone and mood drew out the
whole thing I felt more for the showdown
with Maul and whoever this Jedi than I
did for kylo and radiology like I feel
connected to this man this is great you
can feel the desperation and the
determination clashing together just as
much as you know the lightsabers and the
cool stuff I really love the way that
they did all of the fighting partly
as you know they're all for the most
part lightsaber or force push lights but
they each character had their own energy
about it each character sort of seemed
like they had their own approach to the
fighting style way the choreography
worked out having multiple people
attacking at once in the top of this I
thought worked really naturally too
because sometimes you'll see these and
you'll be like okay good fight
choreography but everyone's going in
wanted it I'm really making use of the
double sided saber for Darth Maul just
adding to both the badassery but also
yeah the authentic fight quality this
gives out like this is so pro well to
bring it to life to where he has a
double bladed lightsaber and then
someone else is dual wielding lifesavers
as well it switched from blades to using
it kind of like a scream of sticks and
the music on top of all that was so
great it wasn't like bombastic but it
was still operatic it struck the right
balance and the visual effects - you're
gonna have to wait geez you don't get
fed for another half hour and the CGI
was also excellent - the sound design
great everything was so crisp here
nothing felt other than the fact that I
was aware that if this was like a studio
produced day it would probably just look
a little sharper here and there but for
the most part anything that falls under
like fan film or independent student
film none of those qualities were here
at all the sound design was absolutely
excellent the visual effects are great
every single shot felt wonderfully
composed you know what it is it felt
lived in it didn't just feel like a
tribute this had me have the thought of
Star Wars Disney Plus whatever should do
a live-action anthology show and getting
these kind of filmmakers involved do
their own thing or begin like there's
other wonderful fan films out there of
Star Wars this has got to be like one of
the absolute best in terms of just
polished and consideration design all
that stuff and even the sophistication
of the shots like it looked like they
had is four years ago but they still
probably could have had drones and stuff
like that like it didn't even seem
grounded and confined to a lot of the
limitations some other fan films that
I've seen have felt not to knock those
but yeah this really did feel like you
were just peering into a little movie
but also it was the perfect length you
know
it feels like the perfect little short
story and then you're done you know you
kind of see how Darth Maul is set out on
to his journey into the rest of the
universe as we know it at least in this
take just all that aura and even just
the little references like the the orb
on the front of that droid reminds me of
Hal 9000 legatee starts to take on these
rich layers that you know you wouldn't
necessarily expect to be able to pull
out of us yeah you know short like this
good job on location scout that's a big
part of what breathe a lot of life into
this when they're in the force and the
treason like all right they kind of good
place to do this scene them they're
shifting locations they're in between
those rocks and they're out in that big
I was great call great call and another
shout out to the guy who played mom
beyond him doing his own thing with the
performance right down to the the the
way he moved as Darth Maul if you told
me Ray Park you know revisited the role
with with this fan film I would have
believed it oh yeah it's ever since he
moves just like hey you know I see here
that they have a teaser trailer for
their cyberpunk 2077 fan film so I got
something else in store right now
alright guys will subscribe to t7 Pro as
soon as you can if you haven't seen this
in full format screen just yet if this
happens of your first time watching with
us please go to the original link as
soon as you can subscribe to the reel
rejects make sure to click that
notification bell thank you to giant
panda king for sponsoring this video hit
up our special link in the description
box titillate yourself and last but not
least patron in the day shout out I want
to shout out Cal durian seep in acoustic
outdoor arena at the time filming this I
know that lately you've been going
through a bit of a rough patch and a lot
of people have during this pandemic time
I know you've experienced a loss very
recent and I'm sorry to hear what you
have gone through it also sounds like
though that you've been able to grieve
through this process I don't mean this
to come across an insensitive way at all
it sounds like you've managed to make
the most of it you've been throwing
yourself back into writing and you'll be
getting a lot of creative things done
lately watching something like a great
fan film and knowing the kind of work
that you admire I just want to encourage
you to keep using whatever emotional
process you have to keep going through
that tunnel till you reach the light
because I'm sure that whatever you got
in store is going to be
that feels very sincere authentic from
the heart on top of that thank you for
all the animal love that you've been
spreading around the world you've been a
great gentleman and great support of the
real rejects and I only want the best
for you buddy thank you so much